welcome dr alok patel world-renowned
pediatrician and specialist in debunking
misinformation and we're in the same
outfit bam
we're about to fight misinformation by
looking at old medical instruments i
don't know if that's misinformation just
be thankful you live in today's time
seriously what we're about to see i'm
scared for he's scared we're all scared
you should be scared
you're pulling that's a i'm like that's
like the lawnmower dude i'm excited just
by like the look of this thing like
possibilities
this is a finger relocating yes
i swear i got it
yeah you put your finger in there and
you pull somebody was either lazy or
just wanted to sell the device i think
we both agree that it's extracted it's
an extractor
to pull a tooth to bolster a place
against the root of the tooth and the
claw over the crown the key was turned
dislocating the tooth oh so you're going
like this
not cool they didn't have sedation back
then remember you know what i'll never
forget about tooth extractions castaway
i thought you were saying you're gonna
remember like the toy box at the
dentist's office this is like the one
thing i remember i got no toys well you
went to like the old rush i went to a
soviet i just i was like you and no
light that came for you i was like you
want a toy you could have toys you have
toy you have toy
oh oh this is beautiful it is pretty
it's a suction or an air blower i think
that's sort of i agree with you
and then where do you put it any hole a
lithium tone the instrument consists of
a handle and blade that's a blade
apparently thus an incision can be made
through a prostate gland or bladder of
six different breaths but on earth 1722
bro they don't know what they were doing
no
oh my god do you insert it in the
urethra i think and then like hold the
blade out and then
open the blade inside and then oh my god
there's oh my god no dude do you see
what i'm saying no i don't want to see
it i don't know i'm like there's no way
that that is small enough to put in your
urethra oh my god i think it is i'd say
keep the stone
this okay this is suction oh wait wait
do you see the middle thing that looks
like a foot pump you're blowing air yeah
yeah it looks like an ambu bag like
it could be to inflate lungs and that
thing takes the fluid out of the lungs
what other thing can you blow into the
human body i mean they were doing some
stupid stuff back then you think this is
like the old school colonoscopy but then
what's the bottoms no well cause they
would wanna you blow air into a
colonoscopy before you do it i don't
know if they knew to do a colonoscopy
okay in the days of doing this thing
tobacco smoking
look at the
blowing in his pictures i could see this
coming back they already have it they
have coffee they sell coffee animals
it's the same thing oh my god indigenous
peoples of north america to stimulate
respiration wait wait they
help people breathe by putting smoke
they know that the butt is not connected
to the lungs they may not have
ah
yes
they look like headphones but it kind of
looks like an apple device is it a
helmet a testicular device i see coils
on it coils mean electricity it could be
electricity or it could mean like hot
water okay so maybe it's a fever
stimulator to treat meningitis da you've
taken a deep dive on that one this is a
brain freeze device you put this on your
head okay you plug this this thing in
like there were no plugs there i don't
know what that what is that white thing
then i'm going one of two options fever
stimulator makes you your head warm to
prevent
infection of some kind of meningitis
probably or two some kind of ect machine
that causes electric shocks to your
brain let's see it brain freeze device
amarotton
cool i also heard something outside whoa
how's that happened we also have one
light going
mri jedi
dude you're gonna get us demonetized to
take mri scans of the brain these
helmets were worn by children and adults
coils are aerials for picking up mri
signals old school do you think this
works
maybe
but i gotta give a shout out to the end
of this description yeah and they named
it a star wars toy so that kids weren't
afraid to put it on smart actually
okay this looks like a ryan webber test
for me okay wow yeah perceptive because
there's a bell on it yeah i don't know
maybe i'm wrong there's something
restrictive about this right but why the
teeth with the angry teeth like maybe
it's so you can't really open your jaw
but you can still get like food in but
what's the purpose of putting the jagged
teeth so you don't put your hand in your
mouth okay is this like a psych device
like
schizophrenia or and the bells so they
don't run away and they can find them i
think we solved this i think i'm the
same a scolds brittle it was an
instrument of punishment and a form of
torture and public humiliation
functioned to silence the victim from
speaking entirely jesus christ this
isn't a medical device it was slid onto
the mouth and pressed down on top of the
tongue with a spike this prevented
speaking and resulted in many unpleasant
side effects including excessive
salivation and fatigue now do you just
ban some from twitter this is the saw
device this should be in a saw movie you
have to tell like you know the
combination
you know the combination and you have to
tell your friend otherwise like the room
is going to implode that is really good
well done it's a dark morbid but on
point this is a medical video next
oh
look at an endoscope like a cheap
endoscope okay
what is this circa time frame do you
think we're looking at i didn't do well
in art history in undergrad to me based
on the number there this is like 1700s i
don't know was the printing press even
invested
it was right yeah this could be this
could be like some some old-school ink
guttenberg when was guttenberg around
who's guttenberg i don't know johannes
gutenberg creator of the printing press
look at that what my guess would same
page i think it's involved in some type
of bloodletting i think it's a
colonoscopy device oh that's my final
speed done artificial leaf okay you said
blood i wasn't that funny you said
bloodletting this instrument allowed for
more precise bloodletting and was often
used to treat areas around the eyes or
temples oh my god
and how do they know what do you think
is going to be the one thing that we're
doing now that we're going to look at
this in a hundred years whoa they did
this to people maybe it's what you said
earlier with a colonoscopy maybe in the
future when we actually see like three
videos the pills why do they put cameras
inside of themselves yeah
oh i've seen this image before i hope
i'm right here because i'm going to give
a little nod to the power of vaccines i
think these are iron lungs oh you might
be right the fact that we don't see
these anymore speaks to the fact that
vaccines work that's a microphone iron
lung higher lung you got one no device
is more associated with polo than the
tank respirator better known as the lung
people who treated acute early stages of
polio so that many patients weren't able
to breathe when the virus actions
paralyzed muscle groups in the chest wow
so this was like the initial intubation
you know what's funny we say like this
looks bad but if you think about how
artificial respirations are now that
looks pretty bad like inserting a tube
into the mouth that's true today
keeping people on paralytics that could
be a barbarian thing that we might
almost look more comfortable yeah
it almost looks like a portable iron
look dude it's breast milk
but just from one thing yeah i don't
know
why
you literally shouted it out
centrifuge that was a good quick guess i
mean like okay so clearly there's a
motor spinning motor rotor a person
wouldn't go in there right unless it was
a hamster what about a baby oh could it
be an incubator yeah i don't know if
you'd be spinning the baby what if just
something outside is spinning for warmth
it seems like really inefficient
it does no that is
first dialysis machine
being considered to be the father of
dialysis dr william kauff constructed
the first dialyzer that's an artificial
kidney right there dude do you see what
he improvised to make it with sausage
skins orange juice cans a washing
machine and other common items to make a
device that could clear the blood of
toxins and we said that sausage isn't
good for you
well that just looks like a functional
ceo i'm just going to say it's it's the
first x-ray cold cancer therapy
well this is really interesting because
now when a patient gets radiation
therapy it's so targeted they have
physicists in the room right to decide
like how to get it in there safely like
the radiation oncologist and the
physicists do so much work to make sure
it's like safe it's the right amount the
right time
it's a stapler it's a nail gun oh you
know what i think you're right because
look at the top part the top part looks
like it clamps down
and then that that needle it looks like
it drives a needle down or something to
staple her hernia tool like this thing
looks awful once doctors repaired the
tear in the muscle they would insert the
hernia tool this thing would be in place
for about a week oh while scar tissue
formed on it now they just put a mesh
and the mesh gets the scar tissue on it
and gets strong this was the mesh back
there so did you walk around you just
had this like thing and you were like
great scoot i heard a
hernia he fishing it looks like the
worst game of laser tag no it looks like
a
vaccine device we see a vial of some
sort that's upside down so clearly
that's going into it's spraying
downwards and you see on the back it has
like a thing a recoil thing maybe it's
like an auto injector no i think it's a
medic like i am injector i would just
stop there which why do you need that
for i am injecting because you're doing
a million in the middle and you're just
kind of like military okay so maybe it's
like you just stand there and you're
going in like an assembly line
jet injector medical device high
pressure and hour stream to penetrate
the skin instead of a needle
these are devices were used in 1960s and
were successful in mass vaccination
efforts okay so the jet stream was so
strong that you didn't even need a
needle that it penetrates the skin dude
that's good which is not like it's got
to hurt it's also now you're now you're
subcutaneous subcutaneous with no
control and also is it spreading like
yeah like what part of the muscle does
it stop it
oh
that's a that's a cutter this is a yeah
this is cutting things dude is that a
castrator it's snipping something tongue
snipper toe stripper
oh my god
open wide dude can you imagine the pain
the bleeding we live in the best time
ever appreciate that you don't have the
tonsil guillotine around
follow dr lok patel all his information
is listed down below and if you want to
see cringy 1950s health films click here
to check those out what they did back
then was just not okay not i believe it
not okay
[Music]